[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory i
hope you all had a happy holidays in
today's video we're going to be
discussing what would have happened in
the series if one of harry potter's most
well-known antagonists draco malfoy had
been sorted into gryffindor house
instead of slytherin for this particular
hypothetical scenario i must admit the
first question i found myself asking was
if sorted into gryffindor would draco
have been more of a peter pettigrew or a
serious black that is to say would he
have played the part of a gryffindor
only to betray his loyalties later and
serve voldemort in secret as pettigrew
did or coming from a pureblood family
infamously known for their ties to the
dark lord and dark arts would he have
openly and with pure intentions shirked
his family's affiliations and ideologies
in favor of the greater good and doing
what was right similarly to sirius black
personally i believe it would have been
the former sorry to any draco fans out
there but i just can't see young malfoy
outright abandoning his anti-muggle
sentiments and pure-blooded favoritism
with the drop of a hat sorting out that
is sorry couldn't help myself
that said i think his time at hogwarts
wouldn't have been nearly as pleasant
for him had he been sorted into
gryffindor i think eventually he would
have found his footing and been just as
confident in his beliefs as he was
pre-sorting ceremony but at first filled
with shock and horror and not having
been placed in sutherin as his entire
family had been before him his arrogance
and self-confidence would have been at
least a little bit shaken
because as you may recall he was so
certain he would be sorted into
slytherin in fact well in advance of the
sorting ceremony he went so far as to
boast a harry that he would most
definitely be placed in slytherin saying
well no one really knows until they get
here do they but i know i'll be in
slytherin all our family have been so
can you imagine how completely
shattering it would have been for young
draco to have been placed in the rival
house of gryffindor his certainty in his
future his sense of self his very
identity which had been infuriatingly
boastful before would have been put into
question
not to mention what his mother and
father would say about this absolutely
terrible news
so i believe that if malfoy had been
sorted into gryffindor we would have
been presented with a more fragile
version of draco at least at first to
begin with he'd feel isolated and alone
having snubbed several of his fellow
gryffindors almost immediately before
the ceremony of course i'm referring to
ron and harry i mean how could we forget
how draco ruthlessly insulted ron
right before offering harry that
handshake outside the great hall and
prior to that draco was so utterly rude
to harry in diagon alley before he knew
that he was the harry potter needless to
say these two boys wouldn't have been
lining up to become best mates with the
young wizard who had so recently
slighted them both
so at least for the first little while i
think draco would have been a bit of a
loner within gryffindor house perhaps he
would have tried to bridge the gap
between the houses to keep his
friendships alive with crab and goyle
the two hogwarts students who were
previously his goonies and who were of
course sorted into sutherin
sadly for malfoy most likely both of
these boys wouldn't have had any
interest in keeping company with a
gryffindor and they certainly wouldn't
have wanted to go back to following
draco's every command imagine following
the orders of a gryffindor highly
unlikely
so after a failed attempt to retain some
semblance of his pre-hogwarts life and
status malfoy may have decided to
approach some of the first-year wizards
in gryffindor perhaps a few students who
he thought could be easily manipulated
like he did with crab and goyal in an
effort to rebuild a new little crew for
himself
i could see him approaching a pure
blooded witch or wizard like say
lavender brown or never long bottom
now i can't really see neville falling
into tight with draco considering his
parents have been tortured to insanity
by death eaters one of whom was
bellatrix the strange draco's aunt but
it's possible someone like lavender may
have been interested in building a
friendship with a potentially powerful
young wizard from a pureblooded family
like malfoy and so draco could have made
an alley or two in this way within
gryffindor
eventually i'd like to think that harry
and ron would have decided to give draco
a second chance after all it wasn't in
either of their natures to be
deliberately cruel
so perhaps in second or third year they
would have started including malfoy in
more things talking to him during meal
times that kind of thing
perhaps they would have even taken it
upon themselves to encourage draco to be
more open-minded about bloodlines
pushing him to give hermione and others
a chance despite their blood status and
for survival reasons i think draco would
have accepted harry and ron's efforts
even tolerating hermione as a friend
but i also think he would have continued
to look down on her and most likely lied
to his family about having any mudblood
friends at school
after all how could he go home each
holiday and not retain his misguided
perceptions of the wizarding world when
his entire family was so steadfast in
their beliefs and loyalties to the dark
lord and as briefly mentioned bellatrix
lestrange was his aunt and she was of
course quite terrifying with relatives
like this it was so close with voldemort
himself it's hard to imagine draco being
able to fully embrace the gryffindor
ideologies and relinquish his family's
loyalties and anti-muggle beliefs
if he had and been found out best case
scenario he may have been banished from
his family worst case killed
so what would this have meant for draco
personally i think it would have
resulted in somewhat of a double life
for him pacifying the likes of harry at
school with the perception that he'd
become more open-minded and hey maybe
sometimes he even believed it himself
but for the most part i think draco
would have still felt above mudbloods
and would have felt duty-bound to uphold
his family's honor ultimately i believe
this would have meant that we wouldn't
have heard as much about malfoy for the
majority of the novels and films perhaps
it would have been featured about the
same amount as say neville longbottom
then as we progressed through the series
he would have become more of a focal
point as i do think draco would have
still been selected by voldemort to
assassinate dumbledore he might have
even been an even more desirable
candidate for this task actually with
his increased accessibility to harry who
was of course very close with dumbledore
what's more there likely would have been
less suspicion about draco being
involved in a secret task for the dark
lord
snape being the triple agent that he was
still would have taken on the
unbreakable vow to protect malfoy but
since he wouldn't have been the head of
draco's house anymore they would have
had to communicate more secretively
personally i think it would have been
really interesting to have not known too
much about where draco's true loyalties
lay throughout the series
similarly to snape it would have been
quite intriguing to have always been
guessing whether or not we could trust
malfoy we may have been constantly
asking ourselves whether he had actually
changed even just a little in the actual
events of harry potter we do get
glimpses of draco wavering in his
loyalties to voldemort later in the
series so it's possible that he could
have converted to fully supporting the
likes of dumbledore harry and the order
of the phoenix instead of voldemort and
the death eaters
however just because someone doesn't
want to blindly follow the orders of a
mass murdering dark wizard doesn't
necessarily mean that they are moral and
good does it and as we've already
discussed i think it would have been
very difficult for malfoy to outright
abandon the beliefs he'd held for so
long
especially with the views of his parents
lucius and narcissa with whom he
remained close as a young wizard
all in all if draco had been sorted into
gryffindor i think malfoy would have
been a more complex and mysterious
character earlier in the series he would
have kept us guessing just like snape
but he mostly would remain the same
person in terms of his beliefs and been
involved in the same major events that
occurred such as its attempted
assassination of dumbledore
this of course brings us to the end of
this video do you agree how do you think
the series would have differed if draco
had been sorted into gryffindor would he
have been a peter pettigrew or
mysterious black let me know your
thoughts in the comments below
and as always if you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel
until next time
imagine being in hufflepuff i think i'd
leave wouldn't you
[Music]
you